تواصل الصين زياده عديد قطعها البحريه في
الممرات المائيه الاستراتيجيه مقد يقود
ويقود لسباق تسلح جديد نشرت بكين اسطولا
من السفن البيضاء المجهزه بمدافع وصواريخ
مضاده للسفن لكنها ليست تابعه للبحريه
الصينيه وبهذا تكون الصين بحسب نيويورك
تايمز استغلت المنطقه الرماديه هذه
المنطقه الفاصله بين السلطات انفاذ
القانون والقوات البحريه في الفتره بين
الثلاثين من مارس الماضي وحتى الثاني من
ابريل احاطت سفن خفر السواحل الصينيه بجزر
سيمكاكو المتنازع عليها مع اليابان لاكثر
من 80 ساعه لتعلن اليابان لاحقا عن خطه
لتطوير خفر السواحل وضمه الى وزاره الدفاع
نيويورك تايمز اعادت التفكير بسعي الصين
لتصبح قوه بحريه عظمى وقيام الرئيس
تشجنبينج في عامه الاول كرئيس للصين
بانشاء
بحريه من خلال دمج خمس جهات مختلفه طبعا
سيكون خفر السواحل في نظر الصين اساسا
يساعدها على التحكم في الممرات المائيه
المهمه وثرواتها المائيه والسمكيه وايضا
المعدنيه وهو ما قاده لاحتكاكات مع قوات
خفر السواحل وسفن صيادين ايضا في كل من
الفلبين وفياتنام وايضا اندونيسيا مؤخرا
وسعت الصين المهمه والقدره القتاليه
لاسطولها بعد اقرار قانون عام 2021 الذي
يمنع خفر السواحل حق استخدام القوه
المميته ضد السفن الاجنبيه يرى ان الصين
بذلك تنتهك القانون الدولي من خلال السماح
لخفر السواح البن انخراطي في سلوك حربي
دون اعلان الحرب وخارج نطاق سلطتها
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات